in the last video we had completed
meiosis 1 and now we're ready to go into
meiosis 2 and you might be wondering
well hey you know after mitosis we went
back into our interphase is there kind
of a rest period between our two phases
of meiosis and the answer is sometimes
there can be a rest period where you
have an interphase - and that will
depend on the type of cell and the
species and all of that but it is
possible so I'll actually I'll actually
put that over here so we could we could
have an interphase - so interphase
interphase - which you could kind of
view as a as a rest period but then we
get into meiosis 2 which will allow us
to complete all of meiosis so you could
imagine meiosis 2 starts with prophase 2
and in prophase 2 now I'm dealing with
two cells here so in prophase 2 and I'm
going to do it for for both of the cells
that I have outside after I finished my
osis one so in prophase 2 so let me
that's one of the cells
I'm not going to space to draw it
properly so let me draw it so let me
draw this one first so this is one of
the cells right over here and then this
is the other cell right over here in
prophase 2 just like in prophase 1 and
just like in prophase in mitosis and let
me write the phases here this is
prophase 2 we're talking about prophase
prophase 2 your nuclear envelope
dissolves again so let me show a
dissolving nuclear envelope so your
nuclear envelope dissolves again and
your and your your chromosomes
once again condensing I guess in todayI
you can see into their denser form so
it's going to look like it's going to
look like this this and this on this
side it has a little bit of the little
bit of the magenta that was from the
chromosomal crossover back in prophase 1
and then you have this character right
over here
that is shorter you have this chromosome
right over here and it has a little
orange section from the chromosomal
crossover just like this and then you
have the shorter orange chromosome just
like that so they have condensed and
you've actually you actually each of
these cells now will have duplicate
centrosomes so the centrosomes have
replicated and they will start they will
start to migrate to opposite to opposite
ends of the cell so once again very
strong analogy especially to frankly
prophase from mitosis so now let's keep
going
we're now ready to go to metaphase to
metaphase to metaphase metaphase 2 and
let me draw my two cells this is one of
them and this is the other let me draw
an arrow here so you can see that we are
entering that we are entering into
another phase so we are entering into
another phase metaphase 2 and you can
just imagine it's very similar to what
happens in metaphase in mitosis and
actually all of meiosis 2 is very
similar to what happens in mitosis so in
metaphase 2 are our centrosomes have
migrated to the poles so our Center is
ohms have migrated to the poles I'm
going to do it twice because I'm now
dealing with two I'm now dealing with
two different cells my nuclear membrane
is now it's now disappeared and I have
my now dense chromosomes lining up along
the equator here so this magenta one
it'll line up right over here so it
might look like that and actually let me
draw all the magenta ones now since I
have my magenta color selected so this
is the longer one in this one this had a
little bit of orange in it let me add a
little bit of the orange here and then I
had this shorter orange chromosome
shorter or orange chromatid on this cell
I had the longer
the larger orange chromosome so ed a
little bit it has a little bit of pink
on it and of course you have your
microtubules that are I've been doing
that in blue so let me continue to do it
in blue that that put that are pushing
the centrosomes apart but are also
attaching to the chromosomes at the
kinetic Wars at the kinetic ores so
there you go and remember this right
over here where the two sister
chromatids attached those are our
centromeres so let me just draw it all
out like this so it might go might be
something like that
and now we're ready for anaphase two and
you could imagine what's about to happen
there things are about to pull apart and
once again this is analogous to what
happens in anaphase in mitosis so let me
so anaphase two and a phase and a Phase
two I'm going to draw my cells again
it's taking me twice as long because I
have to do it for twice as many cells so
that's one cell there this is another
cell here this is I got a centrosome
here centrosome here centrosome here
centrosome here and then the key here is
this is why it's like mitosis and not
like anaphase and meiosis one is instead
of or like in mitosis we're now going to
split the sister chromatids so they now
become two daughter chromosomes when
they're connected they're just to gather
they're viewed as sister chromatids that
make up one chromosome but now they get
now they're getting pulled apart so this
one might get pulled in this direction
and then this one might get pulled in
this direction it has a little bit of
has a little bit of the magenta right
over here and then one of the sister
chromatids which would now be a daughter
chromosome going in upwards and one of
them going downwards and let me draw all
the micro all the microtubules here all
the microtubules that are doing that are
super involved in all of this work of
getting things to the right sides of the
cells and as
to happen in this cell as well so in
this cell so this one might be going
down here and this one is moving up here
and this one had this one had a little
chunk of or in joint so let me draw that
little chunk of orange and then once
again one of the formerly sister
chromatids now daughter chromosomes
going up there and now going down over
here over here
and let me draw all of the microtubules
microtubules that are really well I've
said it multiple times super involved
and in actual the movement going on
there elongating there's these motor
proteins that are moving that are moving
the chromosomes along once again they're
connected at the kinetic [ __ ]
right over here connected the kinetic
cores
all right over there and now we're
almost done we're ready to move into
telophase 2 so we're now going to go
into telophase 2 telophase telophase 2
where my two cells are now becoming four
cells so telophase two I'm going to show
the cytokinesis starting to happen so
telophase two so so turning into four
cells starting so the cytokinesis
happening on in this cell up here I have
this character and has a little bit of
magenta right over here that's this
right over there then you have the
shorter magenta one and actually they
are starting to they're starting to
unravel into their chromatin form so
maybe I'll draw that a little bit and
then this one right over here is trying
to unravel into its chromatin form and
so is that one and whoops I'm gonna do
that in that magenta color starting to
unravel into its chromatin form oh and
do it over here this one is starting to
unravel and so is this one so and so is
and so is having trouble changing colors
and so is that one and then up here this
one's starting to unravel this one over
here and this longer mostly magenta one
is also starting to unravel also
starting to unravel you start having
your nuclear envelope form again so your
nuclear envelope is forming again
nuclear envelope is forming your
microtubules are dissolving let me draw
the centrosomes there outside of the
nuclear envelope outside of the nuclear
envelope and of course you are finally
dividing the cells your cytokinesis
happens so now you have you have your
four your four cells that each have a
haploid number
they each have two chromosomes remember
your diploid number was four the germ
cell had four chromosomes two pairs of
homologous chromosomes now each of your
resulting gametes these are now gametes
now these are gametes they have a
haploid number but we started with a
haploid number at the beginning of
meiosis two so that's why meiosis 2 is
often compared to mitosis so let me make
this clear this right over here is
meiosis 2 because it preserves the
number of chromosomes just like mitosis
so this is my osis meiosis 2 right over
here meiosis 2 we started with a haploid
number and we finished with a haploid
number just like this and now these
gametes are already are ready for some
fertilization it's important to realize
now now these each have two chromosomes
and these are not these are not
homologous chromosomes these are coding
for different genes but then they will
each of these have the potential to fuse
with if this is if this is a a sperm
cell then this could fuse with an egg
and then together they can create a
diploid number of chromosomes it could
have the the full complement of
homologous pairs but that's what these
are for these are for sexual
reproduction